Medical science has advanced an astounding
amount in the last 50 years or so and we can
do things today that a half a century ago
even in that era’s science fiction would
have been considered science fiction.
By the same token though, there were things
done in the 1950s and 1960s that people today
are still skeptical actually happened, like
all those experiments that resulted in a bunch
of two headed dogs.
Said experiments were conducted by one, Vladimir
Demikhov, a Soviet scientist who is noted
as being a pioneer in the field of organ transplantation.
Dr. Demikhov was responsible for, amongst
other things, pioneering the use of immuno-suppressants
in organ transplants and designing the “first
mechanical cardiac-assist device”, essentially
the precursor to modern artificial hearts.
With this latter device, Demikhov was able
to take over the cardiac function of a dog
for around five hours, an experiment notable
for being “the first ever in which circulation
was maintained in an animal whose heart had
been excised”.
Prior to Demikhov, this was a feat that many
believed to be impossible.
Demikhov is also known to have performed the
first heart transplant in 1946, in this instance
on a dog; this was a full 21 years before
the first human transplant took place and
was a major step towards the latter ever happening.
It has been noted that Demikhov was a genius
whose “successes heralded the era of modern
heart and lung transplantation”.
Despite this glowing praise in some circles,
his contributions have largely been overlooked
outside of the medical community due to the
infamy of his later, more audacious experiments.
This brings us back to the two headed dogs.
Sometime in the early 1950s, spurred on by
the success of his experiments involving the
transplantation of organs in dogs, including
several experiments in which he’d managed
to successfully transplant multiple organs
of the same type into the same animal, Demikhov
began toying with the idea of transplanting
the most valuable organ of all- the brain.
Demikhov is said have been inspired by the
work of his peer, Dr Sergei Brukhonenko, another
Soviet medical pioneer known for inventing
a machine capable of artificially simulating
the functionality of the heart and lungs,
albeit on a temporary basis.
Like Demikhov, the work of Brukhonenko is
largely overlooked due to an experiment involving
dogs.
In Brukhonenko’s case, he infamously kept
the decapitated heads of several dogs alive
using the aforementioned machine for a number
of hours, proving that it was possible to
keep the brain alive and functional after
almost unthinkable trauma.
Footage of these experiments appears in a
documentary released in 1940 aptly titled
“Experiments in the Revival of Organisms”.
However, the veracity of this footage, which
shows a decapitated dog’s head connected
to a heart lung machine blinking and responding
to various stimuli, has been the topic of
heated debate for many years and even to this
day, there’s no agreement on whether it
actually shows what it claims.
To be clear, Brukhonenko’s experiments on
reanimation are well documented and there’s
little doubt they actually took place as he
claimed.
However, there is some uncertainty about whether
the particular documentary actually shows
real experiments or whether it was a reenactment
of sorts after the fact for propaganda purposes.
Getting back to Demikhov, his idea was as
simple as it was shocking.
He would prove that the brain, like any other
organ, could be successfully transplanted
by cutting the head off a dog, keeping it
alive using the same technology as Brukhonenko
had done, and then transplanting it onto the
body of another dog.
All in all, it’s recorded that Demikhov
performed this experiment “over 24 times”
with varying degrees of success- success in
this context meaning that the subjects survived
the ordeal and even displayed some awareness
of their surroundings and the ability to respond
to stimuli.
After successful transplants, the dogs typically
died days later as a result of immune responses.
Of course, scientists being good scientists,
many were skeptical that Demikhov could actually
perform such a procedure successfully- they
wanted direct proof.
So to silence the skeptics, Demikhov invited
LIFE magazine to document and photograph one
of his experiments in 1959.
The resulting article, titled “Russia Two-Headed
Dog” documented the entire transplant procedure
including the preliminary preparations, during
which Demikhov introduced the journalist writing
the article to the two dogs he was about to
sew together, Shavka, a small 9 year old female,
and Brodyaga, a large stray of which little
was known.
two-headed-dog2Demikhov then further “endeared”
himself to any potential readers by saying
that Brodyaga was Russian for “Tramp”
and that he personally felt the dog was quite
lucky since “two heads are better than one”.
Prior to the actual operation, Demikhov also
introduced the interviewing journalist to
a dog called Palma, which he revealed had
two hearts thanks to an operation he performed
on the animal a few days earlier.
The article culminated in Shavka’s head
and fore legs being successfully grafted onto
Brodyaga’s body.
The operation was such a success, in fact,
that Shavka’s decapitated head was even
able to lap a few mouthfuls of water from
a bowl with some assistance, something Demikhov
did purely for the cameras present as Shavka’s
throat was not attached to Brodyaga’s stomach,
meaning it couldn’t gain any nourishment
from food or water via normal means.
In the end, the two dogs survived for four
days before dying from complications of the
surgery, which came as a surprise to Demikhov
who revealed that some of his previous subjects
had survived for as long as 29 days.
two-headed-dog-1Despite the potential implications
of Demikhov’s research, this particular
bit of his life’s work was largely dismissed
by the wider scientific community with the
exception of a few scientists, most notably
American neuroscientist Dr. Robert White,
who infamously and successfully repeated the
experiment using rhesus monkeys in the 1970s.
While the two experiments were basically the
same and set out to prove the same point-
that a full head transplant was possible-
there were a number of differences.
Beyond the fact that a monkey head transplant
is much closer to the procedure needed for
a human head transplant, which is the end
goal of this research, Demikhov had attached
the head of one dog to the body of another,
still living dog, while White went one step
further and transplanted the head of one monkey
onto a headless monkey body.
Doing this meant that, with the exception
of the spinal cord, every major artery and
even the windpipe and throat could be connected
successfully to the new host body, allowing
for more or less normal body function, other
than the typical issues associated with paralysis.
What’s more, the transplanted monkey head
retained full awareness of its surroundings
to such an extent that literally the first
thing it did upon regaining consciousness
was bite the finger of a medical assistant.
With these results in hand, White concluded
that performing the same surgery on a human
would soon be possible and that the person
would not only potentially survive, but suffer
few ill effects other than the obvious (then)
irreversible damage to their spinal cord,
something that wouldn’t be an issue for
terminal quadriplegics, who White felt would
be the best candidates for such a procedure.
However, he also stated,
Whether such dramatic procedures will ever
be justified in the human area must wait not
only upon the continued advance of medical
science but more appropriately the moral and
social justification of such procedural undertakings.
Others have also taken up the research area
despite the ethical controversy, citing the
massive benefit such procedures would provide
to countless individuals, such as those with
terminal cancer, severe muscular atrophy,
paralysis from the neck down, people with
multiple organ failure, etc.- essentially,
anyone who has an otherwise fully functional
brain, but whose life support systems (in
sum comprising their body) are failing in
some way, which ultimately would cause the
premature death of the brain.
head-transplantAs to the current state of
this brand of research, Italian neurosurgeon
Sergio Canavero states that he expects the
technology will be ready as soon as 2017 to
perform a successful human head transplant.
He even has a candidate lined up for the procedure,
Valery Spiridonov (pictured right), who suffers
from Werdnig–Hoffmann disease and whose
health is declining significantly as he ages.
For Spiridonov, there will come a time when
his only hope of survival is transplanting
his head to a donated body, at which point
even a slim chance of success in such a surgery
is preferable to the alternative.
Not satisfied to leave the head transplanted
individual paralyzed, Dr. Canavero even managed
to re-knit the spinal cord of a rat after
severing it, allowing the animal to eventually
regain control of its body.
German researchers in 2014 also reported similar
success repairing a severed spinal cord in
a rat using a similar technique.
Said Canavero, “This experiment is an important
piece of our puzzle because now we know for
sure that it is possible for a spinal cord
to grow back together.”
Beyond Dr. Canavero, arguably the world leader
in head transplants is one Dr. Ren Xiaoping
of China who has led a team that has made
significant advancements in the procedures
in this arena.
Dr. Canavero recently commented on Dr. Xiaoping’s
work, “I can tell you that within the last
18 months, about 1,000 similar surgeries were
performed in China, and I can say that this
very rat (the one with the repaired spinal
cord) is not the best sample.
We will say more as soon as the information
is published in the scientific magazines,
because until then it is restricted by copyright.”
As for Dr. Xioaping, he noted of the ethics
of the procedure that back when things like
human heart transplants were first becoming
a real possibility, there was just as much
controversy surrounding if this area of research,
let alone applying it to a human procedure,
was morally acceptable or not, and that “many
people say a head transplant is not ethical.
But what is the essence of a person?
A person is the brain, not the body.
The body is just an organ.”
Essentially, the body is just a magnificent
life support system.
For some, theirs fails resulting in an otherwise
healthy brain that might have lived many more
years dying as well.
Beyond practicing procedures on cadavers,
presently Dr. Xioaping and his team have successfully
transplanted numerous heads of rats and other
animals onto new host bodies, including transplanting
monkey heads, which, as previously noted,
is a relatively similar procedure to transplanting
a human head.
Dr. Xioaping reported that (currently) a monkey
head transplant takes approximately 20 hours
to complete and he expects a human head transplant
to take an additional 10-20 hours.
However, before Dr. Xioaping is willing to
try the procedure on an otherwise terminal
human patient, he stated that advancements
still need to be made to ensure an extremely
high probability of success.
Towards this end, he and his team are working
on improving methods to cut the spinal cord
cleanly enough to allow for a high probability
of reconnecting to the spinal cord in the
new body, advancements in suppressing organ
rejection, and ability to better maintain
blood pressure to the brain throughout the
procedure to ensure no brain damage.
Despite the technical obstacles remaining
and some amount of public opposition to such
human procedures, even if they ultimately
are life saving for many with otherwise terminal
conditions, Dr. Xioaping posited in March
of 2016,
We are getting closer and closer to our goal
of a human head transplant.
I don’t have a timetable.
It is very complex work.
We can’t say it will happen tomorrow – but
I am not ruling out next year.